I say this is how the real doggy Style's
done
[Music]
hi I'm Ali mikovsky and I'm here to
answer the internet if your dad and your
boyfriend switched bodies oh boy and the
only way to get them back to normal is
to bang one of them which one would you
[ __ ] I think I'm gonna have to [ __ ] my
dad's body with my boyfriend's brain my
dad he's a large man so I don't think
that the penis would be fully insert you
know
that is wild I got a big belly it
probably won't be too much contact
I don't know
who is the one person in the world you
would least want to bang your
significant other probably my dad yeah I
think if my dad banged my boyfriend my
dad's kind of charming and I think my
boyfriend might like it
and I would be worried that my dad is
going to steal my man watch out Larry
you dirt bag which celebrity that
everyone thinks is hot
um but you disagree about I'm gonna go
with Jason Momoa he's too big I don't
like a big or like the rock like anyone
who's just jacked it's like for what why
do you need to be that jacked for the
apocalypse just go just go just die I
love Vin Diesel you know I I he's he's
bald so I feel like that's kind of like
it balances out yeah there's something a
little bit rugged about Vin Diesel but I
feel like Jason Momoa the long hair the
big body the tan skin
um
he needs like a crooked nose or like a
wonky eye or something is jerking off to
webcam girls cheating oh
huh hmm no I don't think so no it's like
interacting with her no if jerking off
to webcam girls cheating no unless
you're like come unless they don't have
a lot of viewers and they know that
you're also like then that's weird yeah
if they're saying your username or your
name then definitely they shouldn't know
that you exist but okay
[Music]
like in the same room IRL Subway yeah I
mean if I don't know no harm no foul if
I see it going down then yeah it's weird
but if I don't know go off King I would
I would feel flattered I think if I you
know yeah if I'm on the subway and I
don't know and someone's jerking off but
they're like looking at me yeah
thank you yeah thank you Mary [ __ ] kill
Brad Pitt Matthew McConaughey Channing
Tatum he's following me on Instagram
whoa I don't want to put it on blast
because I think if he realizes he's
following me he might unfollow did you
[ __ ] marry him and kill him I'll
marry him because that's the polite
thing to do in this situation I'm gonna
have to have sex with Matthew
McConaughey because I feel like he would
do some like weird Spirit like he would
cleanse my aura in the process of it he
would probably do I read his book He's a
trip I would have to kill Pitt he's too
he's too sexy he's too hot I would feel
like a frumpy troll I don't have the
self-esteem to [ __ ] Brad Pitt would you
rather go back to being 18 years old
knowing everything you know now or get a
million dollars oh like um I'll go back
to being 18 years old and I'll invent
Uber and then I'll have a bunch of money
garyvee said he got pitched on it when
it was like initial investing where like
rich people get to invest in it first
yeah he was like this is so dangerous
people are gonna like get kidnapped and
he was right
I think more than anything like I'd
rather go back to being 18 not to like
invent an app or get rich but just to
like um have a little more fun and be a
little bit sexier and have a little more
confidence and like take more [ __ ]
photos yeah yeah I think I'd just have
more fun being 18. you just go back and
yeah and I'd probably I don't drink
anymore so I'd probably get like even
more [ __ ] up knowing that it's gonna
end yeah yeah
absolutely would you rather give up
appetizers or desserts for life I would
definitely easily desserts buy buy
desserts I don't need them really yeah I
love like a Savory snack so yeah like a
calamari a fried calamari like a
breadstick a garlic bread no I love
calamariated yesterday it's an elastic
it's a rubber band yeah I don't eat it
up Yum Yum Yum Yum Yum I'll eat a hair
band if it was deep fried I don't care
can you still go oh my gosh okay can you
still go to your hair stylist if she is
very racist no I mean I just had an
experience at a at a service
um I don't wanna I don't want to put
them on blast because I tag them when I
get my stuff done but she said something
that was questionably it was like it was
like subtle racism where it's not like
outright like I hate these people but
the context of what she was saying was
racist and I was just kind of I I was
like she does a good job
I like tried to say something to be like
well maybe yeah I think you still gotta
go You're Not Gonna Change the World by
not getting a service done by this
person and you can slowly you know kind
of uh uh you're not letting her like
raise your kids yeah yeah so I would
still go to them
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blonde child who has the greatest
voice of our generation are you killing
the kid
um probably I mean I think it depends on
context like we don't need another child
singer or Star we have plenty of those
and if I'm young and I shouldn't die
then I will kill the child in order for
me to live but if this is like a
question for when I'm maybe older or I'm
sick then let that child's child unless
the kid was doing something good for
Humanity besides just entertainment
cure cancer okay then he can live yeah
my life is not worth other people
potentially not living
is their life
I don't know if I want to live that bad
would you rather get caught masturbating
or [ __ ] your pants in public well
I've done both I think I'd rather get
caught [ __ ] my pants I think that's
like a universal experience I think a
lot of people would have sympathy for me
it's also kind of a power move to be
honest you're like I could use the
bathroom but why not there's something
very freeing about shedding your pants
it feels very like tribal and ancestral
like if there's something I'm like wow
I'm the person on this Earth getting
caught masturbating in public is like
why why just wait Justice for Pee-wee
Herman TBH at a movie theater I get I
mean that's kind of that feels intimate
he's almost alone although yeah I used
to work at a movie theater and I would
have to kick people out for masturbating
and I'm like just let them finish if
your arms were Spaghetti would you want
them to be cooked or uncooked oh I think
uncooked would be more fun
um you just be or no no cooked I want
them to be cooked yeah I want them to be
loose and fun they can stick onto [ __ ]
you can grab things easy
um really good at dance parties I think
uncooked would be really stressful it
would break so easily yeah let's say
that they're down to break that's
it yeah but no I like I like cooked I
like them loose I like them fun more
fraying
yeah definitely cook spaghetti should
you lock a dog out of the room when
you're having sex uh no I put my dog in
a cage in the bedroom and make him watch
say this is how the real doggy style is
done
you can learn a thing or two Benjamin
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out